hey guys and welcome to another freet
to-play moneymaking video today I'm
going to be making something similar uh
to my from scratch to bond uh episode in
11 hours I'm going to for one see if I
can beat that time and two just explore
a bunch of different uh methods for free
to play that didn't go over in the last
one of course there will be some
overlapping uh money makers but for the
most part I'm going to try to stick to
some new ones uh so we're going to set
20 hours on the clock I well let's see
if I can beat the 11 hour time I set
last time uh so to start off I need to
pick up something on the ground uh we'll
just check my bank quickly I have to
cheuck a couple items but uh nothing in
my inventory uh only a couple
untradeables in my bank which I don't
really want to drop and the grand
exchange is fully empty so I'm just
going to pick up a couple random things
to begin with here and then I'm going to
go um do something actually I did last
time uh because I think it's probably
the quickest way to get money um just a
little bit of money to begin with is
just to pick items off the ground and
then go pick up our Buy some stuff from
the shops in verac just a lot easier and
more accessible then after that we'll
try to Branch out into some new stuff
okay so we got a full inventory of ashes
and a Tinder Box so nothing too special
and I'll tell you a little bit of my
game plan here so we'll instant sell
this off uh so to start off I want to uh
eventually start telegrabbing the wines
of zamak I Didn't Do It last time and it
is one of the best moneymakers for free
to play the problem being is that there
are a lot of bots there not a lot of
Worlds so it makes it a little
challenging uh to actually get the wines
uh but I've done a little testing and it
is possible to be the bot out if you're
clicking uh properly and you're standing
correct distance away so I'm going to
battle the Bots for it because I think
you get 300K an hour uh at least there
and that's a great uh way to get our
cash dech started uh from there I'm
going to be doing some set combinations
which I'll explain of course in a little
bit uh but seems pretty profitable but I
will need a bit of money to start with
um so now I'm going to run down here to
the um clo store this just works pretty
easy it's just a really easy way to get
a little bit of cash started all I do is
just look at the items here two coins
cost 80 on the grand exchange great buy
that blue skirt two coins and cost uh 95
on the grand exchange buy that perfect
and we'll just go through a couple
different items here let's see black
skirt uh 366 I don't know about that but
we'll give it a try and then once you've
just kind of gone through all the items
you just hop worlds really easy but uh
easy money okay there we go we just did
this for about 10 minutes a little bit
less and I ended up with a pretty vague
collection of a bunch of different
random stuff uh we'll see which one that
ends up actually selling for the most uh
but hopefully we'll get uh well between
5 and 10K is all i'll really need uh one
thing I could also consider buying is
actually energy potions CU my last run
of this uh they were not free to play uh
but they have been made recently free to
play so that will be a little bit
helpful although I don't think I'm going
to buy one right yet cuz they are 500
coins each uh a little bit pricey so now
what I'm going to do is uh buy the runes
uh for well as many um telegraphs as I
can as well as a couple teleports uh to
fador as well as back to rock for the
grand exchange so we can save quite a
bit of time so let's go ahead and sell
off this junk and see what it ends up
selling for uh black skirts we sell for
that much I guess it will oh that's
really nice actually how much do those
sell for each 2011 wow it's kind of
surprising actually uh and then I'll
drop these down
more and those insta sold nice uh Brown
aprons drop those down good uh pre SCS
drop those down as well perfect hit
collect and we're up to 9k not bad uh
pink skirt see if those inst to cell
didn't okay and a pre gown that was a
mistake didn't mean to buy that but oh
well uh so we have two dead things we'll
just take out not worth wasting offer
slots with that anyway we got about 9
okay that's perfect uh now I'm going to
start off by buying some law runes which
I'll need for the telegraphs as well as
the
teleports and I we'll go
for I guess 40 I don't really need
anything else right now uh so wall runes
I'm going to need some air runes a
little more than that I'm not going to
bother with the air staff yet because um
it's better to get the cast off I would
say 40 and I'm going to need some air
runes and I'll need just a couple other
random runes like fire runes I'll need
to teleport to the gr exchange as well
as uh we'll need some water runes for
the teleport to
valador now one thing I meant to go over
earlier is actually my stats now the
only stat I really have leveled up is my
magic it's pretty much a brand new
account I have a little bit of HP levels
but nothing else I mean you can get this
easily in a day uh pretty much a brand
new account so yeah let's go ahead and
teleport to falor and I'll start uh
telegraphing the wines this is like
really really intense I'm battling at
least two Bots at a time uh I missed out
on so many before I found a world with a
little bit less Bots as well as figured
out the best technique for telegraphing
them uh cuz when you I missed eight
times out of four uh so not a great
start hopefully from now on I'll be able
to get most of them and stop wasting all
my runes I'll see if I can get the next
one because uh it's about 30 seconds
between uh the spawns which
[__] okay that was a fair bit of a
struggle uh but I did manage to get a
full inventory but I used every single
uh Rune that I bought so 40 and I lost
about only an extra four or five after
my last checkin uh so let's go ahead and
sell off all these wines of zamra uh
looks like they actually dropped a
little bit unfortunately but that's
still going to be about uh 55k which
isn't too bad took about 15 minutes uh
so I'll go do this for an hour just to
see if it's worth it in free to play uh
because it is a pain to actually
telegrab the items but it's getting a
little bit later so maybe it'll be a
little less competition so go ahead and
buy some more runes and I'll be back in
an hour or two okay I'm straight up
tired of these stupid Bots that just put
the stupid question mark and beat me
okay got it nice uh they don't beat me
most of the time but it's still really
IR stupid question mark uh but anyway we
are pretty much done uh the hour a
little bit longer possibly but well we
got into the groove of it I definitely
lost occasionally a couple to the Bots I
feel like some of these Bots are
programmed better than others but either
way it's a lot of work but the money is
pretty good for I can't do this and talk
at the same time anyway it's pretty good
for not having a huge requirement and
you don't require any cash to begin with
unlike a few of the uh future methods
I'm going to be using do acquire a
little bit of money so I'm just going to
end up uh using the last two cast here
and see if I can get it and we get the
last one we did not okay well anyway
let's head back to the Grand exchange
and I didn't bring a law Rune okay so
we're back at the Grand exchange and we
can see how many I got in an hour it
looks like 125 wines of zamra uh could
have been better could have been worse
of course so I'll go ahead and sell
these off and see how much uh money I'll
get from them uh unfortunately the
prices are down it would be 300 plus but
right now I'm getting about
283k and now we're still pretty good for
uh the amount of bots that were there so
anyway now I have about 300K to work
with what am I planning next and that is
is I believe to make some sapphire
necklaces if we go price check a
sapphire necklace um the price is about
1,300 and since The Inferno just
actually came out today uh the prices of
gems uh specifically sapphires have
dropped okay so we price check the price
of sapphires 1300 minus 901 and I will
price check the gold bar uh which is
pretty
cheap uh it's anyway it's around 90 or
80 or something so that's
about oh well 1,300 almost I'm going to
be getting on the sapphire necklaces so
300 each that's pretty good so first of
all I need to go ahead and level up my
crafting uh so I'll have to do that as
part of the challenge so let's see here
I'll go buy some leather it shouldn't
cost too much but we'll just start off
with well 100 leather and a needle and
some thread okay guys we're just at
level 17 crafting just checking in here
quickly uh we did have all our offers
come through for the 200 gold bars and
sapphires which is good so once we're
done uh getting into 22 crafting I
believe is what's required to make the
sapphire necklace we'll be good to go
it's only it's really not going to take
that long only about 15 minutes to get
from Level 1 to 22 crafting roughly just
using leather armor it's going to cost
me about 750 to 70k which is a little
unfortunate but it's not the end of the
world and uh hopefully we can make ourl
money back from the sapphire
necklaces all right guys there we go
there's level 22 crafting just finish it
up with leather chaps uh now we can make
these sapphire necklaces another option
is sapphire rings I'll have to check uh
which one ends up being worth uh it to
make more sapphire rings will sell
quicker uh but the necklaces I think
have a better margin on them but we'll
go check so we have 200 gold bars and
200 uh Sapphire so we'll head to alarid
and start crafting them okay so we just
finished up the 200 sapphire rings just
as kind of a test run and we'll finish
up these last five now I I think I in my
head I miscalculated this a little bit I
thought I was going to be getting uh 27
in inventory but or 26 sorry we only get
13 in inventory cuz they both combined
together so I think this will be maybe
200k an hour which isn't bad for how
easy an AFK it is uh but I thought it
was 400k when I first started cuz I'm an
idiot but anyway there we go 200 Rings
crafted and we'll see how much we made
okay so I made about 60k on the sapphire
rings which is good
uh well it's okay but I think I need a
little bit more money before I can start
doing this like 100% because I was only
able to do this for 15 minutes before
having to come back to the Grand
exchange okay guys I ended up getting
quite a bit more this hour uh which is
awesome we just finished up another hour
well roughly it may have taken a little
bit longer but we'll finish up this
inventory and luckily there's only one
person here now it's gone later at night
and I've ended up getting quite a bit
more of the wnes of Zam per hour getting
up pretty much every time I'll watch me
not get this time okay there we go
perfect uh so we got full inventory I'll
just teleport back to verac and uh see
how many wines I ended up getting all
right we're back at the gr exchange so
let's check how many we got this hour
and looks like 138 wines of zamra were
obtained and we have 251k in cash so
let's go ahead and sell these off
quickly and looks like they're going to
be worth uh a little bit under uh
320k or something so we have to drop
down a little bit more unfortunately the
wies of zamak have crashed this month a
bit but still looks like we're going to
sell them for 300
117k all right so we went ahead and
bought another 500 gold bars and another
500 sapphires we're going to go ahead
and craft them and uh yeah hopefully we
can actually get a little bit more of a
profit this time but let's see how long
as it will take okay there we go we just
finished up all the Rings uh so let's go
ahead and price check this in the grand
exchange all right so we got 500 rings
to sell and we're going to sell them for
hopefully about 12280 again so that's
643k and we'll drop it down let see how
much we sell it for 6 41 so let's go
ahead and calculate the money per hour
here all right so we take 641 take off
the cost of The Sapphires and the cost
of the gold bars and we're left with
125k in profit uh we're going a bit slow
on this one so I think it could be a bit
better but I think say 200k an hour
would kind of be the max okay so I'm
going to do another 600 uh gold bars I
want to keep doing this until I can do
this for a full hour which is going to
be about 700 800 and then we'll see
actually how much I make making the hour
so we'll go ahead and collect this and
go ahead and create uh I think we're
still going to make the sapphire rings
but let's just check the necklaces it
might be worth a little more uh actually
1,300 uh they probably won't sell as
quick though I don't think it's worth it
just for that extra bit of money and
we'll go ahead and continue making the
Rings okay so I'm back and I did end up
selling all of the sapphire rings and
crafting them all uh so I ended up
making on about 45 minutes of work about
152 K so this is probably 200k plus an
hour which isn't too bad actually for
the requirement uh but you do kind of
need a little bit of money to start with
uh it is definitely much less or much
more AFK than the zamak of wine method
but uh less money per
hour definitely worth it though I'd say
because uh telegraphing those stupid
wines can be extremely annoying uh but I
think I'm going to do one more hour of
this just to get a true hours test and
then uh I'll go ahead and move on to
something else so let's go ahead and I
think I can probably do oh not the ring
sorry I can probably do 800 in an hour
and I still think it's probably worth
doing the Rings over the necklaces 800
will run at 765k I think we should have
enough for that okay there we go so I
ended up selling off all these sapphire
rings I decided about halfway to go stop
by the grand exchange and sell them off
uh cuz while they do sell pretty quickly
uh once we're getting to this amount
created I thought it'd be better off to
kind of sell them half and half but
anyway collect everything and we're at
over a m so that's pretty exciting only
like two times more to go cuz the bond
is actually 2.8 mil right now okay guys
so now what I'm going to be doing is uh
creating some armor sets uh now I've
decided on the adamant uh set LG because
it has a margin of let's see
here uh 1.6k and it really does not cost
too much uh so yeah let's go ahead do
and do that we've put in an offer for 40
so far insta bot quite a few pieces uh
for those who don't know all I'm doing
is going to be buying the individual
pieces and combining in them into armor
sets uh so we actually have to pull out
an offer here and then we're going to
put in an offer for the adant kite
Shield okay so for the adamant kite
Shield I'll put it in for like 3050
something like that okay so everything
uh will be bought pretty soon so once I
bought them I will go ahead and combine
them and while they're selling I'll
probably do another hour of telegraphing
the
wines okay the rest of the sets came
through pretty quickly so we'll go ahead
and collect all of that and now we're
just going to come here to the sets
category part and find the adamant set
LG there we go 40 have been combined now
based on the G Tracker price here it
looks like it's around 19k but I'll
lower it a little bit and put it at
19700 and uh let's see how much money
we'll make off of this so on each set
I'm making 1.3k which is pretty good so
on the 40 sets I'll be making 52k uh
really easy to do we'll go ahead and do
the other uh well I guess the limit's
125 actually on this I think uh the sets
is 125 the armor is 70 so I don't know
we'll do a little bit more but anyway
really easy money and we'll just wait
for that to sell uh now I'm going to go
do another maybe a little longer
actually I'm going to go Telegraph the
runes or the Wes of zamra for 2 hours I
think cuz I think it's the best money in
the game that haven't really gone over
yet uh so why of zamak we're need L
runes and yeah I think I'm going to do
this for just grind up two hours and
just really H get enough money to
complete one of the last
methods okay another reasonbly
successful run of the wines of zamak uh
now my armor sets actually have still
not quite sold off yet a lot more time
consuming for this than I thought was
going to be I only have five left to
sell uh but I don't know if I'm do the
rest of these that being said it's quite
an Easy Money Maker uh leaving this off
for an overnight they're coming through
reasonably quickly but not as quick as
I'd hope uh but still not too bad uh now
for how many wines of zamak ended up
with uh looks like I got
248 uh in 2 hours which is pretty decent
a little bit less than I did for my last
run but still I think the wines of Zam
possibly are worth a bit more
now uh 566k and we got
572 uh which is really nice
283k plus we have another okay there we
go I was confused there for a second uh
we have 226k in the bank there we go uh
brings up up to 1.5 mil uh which is
awesome and we have uh just a couple
more of these sets to sell uh so I don't
know if I'm do any more of these but one
thing I'm going to now try is uh buying
fire runes and uh Rune packs and air
runes Earth runes whatever out of the
Rune shop I didn't do that last time but
it is one of the best ways to make money
in runes so let's go over there and I'll
show you how okay guys so I'm at the
Rune shop and this is pretty much all
you do so you're going to come here and
you're going to buy out the Rune backs I
do the air packs or the fire packs uh CU
they sell the quickest on the grand
exchange and then all you're going to do
is Spam click them open you can click
and wait uh but it takes a lot longer
but it's a lot more AFK but I wouldn't
recommend it cuz this is going to be
click intensive no matter what you do
you might as well just click harder uh
another Thing Worth doing is buying the
death runes out you can see uh they're
worth 275 on the GE and only 220 or
something in the shop which is pretty
good and then once the world is kind of
low you just hop worlds uh you can also
try Betty's magic Emporium if this place
is a little bit more packed but I
haven't found too big of an issue here
just buy the Rune packs and the death
runes and open them up all right so I'll
do this until I run out of money and
we'll see how much we make off 1.5
mil okay so there we go I bought a
shitload of runes I'm a little tired of
this though uh so we'll start off by
selling off my death runes cuz those
will sell pretty much instantly without
losing too much money okay we got 153k
in death runes and now I'm going to pop
in I don't even know which one first I
didn't think that I only had three offer
slots so this is a bit of a mistake uh
but that's okay these should sell
reasonably quickly all we're going to
sell them for five coins each so we're
going to make uh7 on each Rune uh which
doesn't sound like a lot but it'll add
up over time and
well actually maybe I should pop one of
these slower selling runes in first and
then move over to the fire Rune
later uh and put these in here okay so
we have 300 coins left or 300K left and
uh since I used all my money on buying
these room packs and we have to wait for
them to sell uh now I'm kind of forced
to do uh a meth the dead doesn't require
any money so I'm going to think of one
maybe we'll do W of zamak again but
let's see if there's anything else all
right guys so we're back from our run of
the W of zamra ended up with 227 this
time uh which isn't too bad but we did
sell off all the runes so let's go ahead
and calculate how much I made off those
uh to begin with here so we started with
15 50k keep that in mind so we'll add up
all the costs of the runes that we sold
them for and then take off how much
money we had to begin with so 1738
1550 it's 188k in
about 30 40 minutes uh so close to 300K
an hour but kind of timeconsuming to
sell the runes I wouldn't buy the water
or Earth runes because they took about
twice as long to sell off anyway let's
sell off these wines as well and uh
hopefully we can sell them for this
price good so that's another 550k we're
up to 2.2 mil we're getting really close
to the bond I think right now the price
is a little bit lower it's about 2.6 mil
2.7 mil so we need about 500 more K and
I think we might do some
flipping okay so we have a pretty good
flip for the Rune kite Shields coming in
we sold them for 32970 each and flipped
60 almost 60 56 of them I think uh for
80k profit which is pretty decent
bringing us up to about
2300 all right next up I'm going to try
flipping the hill giant club uh looks
like 965 and 988 it's not too bad and
should trade reasonably quickly uh I
couldn't imagine it taking more than a
couple minutes to buy and sell one of
these so 966 we'll try buying Hill giant
club for
966 and we can afford
two okay so we flipped the hill giant
clubs uh six times it looks like and uh
22k on each club uh so 44k per flip and
we flipped it well three times so that's
well 120ish K uh really nice from the
hill giant clubs next up I think we
might do the
Gilded kite Shield maybe we'll have a
look at some of the items okay so we
actually ended up switching to the team
Cape X which worked quite a bit better
we can see here uh well two or three
four traded every hour uh but a much
bigger margin 1468 into like 1522 this
is the actual margin I ended up getting
1446 into
1539 ended up flipping it three times so
I think we might have enough money for a
bond 2.7 mil right now uh let's go have
a look at the price of a bond on G
tracker quickly uh cuz it has been
crashing today so I might might lock out
and get it otherwise we may have to try
to flip another one of these but that'll
just hurt my time longer cuz we're up to
what 13 hours so I didn't uh beat my
last time but that being said I was kind
of stuck to doing some of the less good
money makers but all right I think we
might able to buy it let's try
it old school bond let's go
and we're going to do
2700k can we buy the bond yes we can
there we go stop the time 6 hours and 46
minutes remaining so it took 13 hours
and 15 minutes this time uh to get a
bond on old school RuneScape and free to
play so once again uh it's quite a lot
of work and quite challenging to get a
bond in free to play but it can be done
in a one dedicated day if you want to I
wouldn't recommend it cuz it's not my
favorite gameplay but it is challenging
and I do I enjoy the challenge of it so
hope you guys enjoyed the video and I
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]